second Russia Africa Summit in Saint
Petersburg has come to an end
but Vladimir Putin is hoping it will
Mark the beginning of Russia's new plan
for Africa he's seeking a bigger role
similar to that of the Soviet Union in
the past Century
many people here know that the Soviet
Union and Russia never assumed that we
should only buy raw materials from
Africa how many Enterprises power plants
steel factories that the Soviet Union
build in Africa we must return to this
practice as my colleague has just said
and we will do this both bilaterally and
on International platforms
at the summit the Russian president
pledged to maintain grain supplies to
Africa laying the blame on the west for
soaring Global food prices he also
announced writing off 23 billion dollars
of African debts the establishment of an
African Russian security coordination
mechanism and most importantly discuss
the peace plan for Ukraine presented by
African leaders
President Putin has shown us that he is
ready to dialogue and find a solution
now we need to convince the other side I
hope we can do that we have established
once again that it can be done and this
gives us optimism we are acting as a
mediator we will talk to one side and
the other I hope that we will achieve
positive results
nothing has really changed from last
June when the initiative was first
announced I think
Africa they know too well that brokering
a deal to end the war won't be an easy
task but in the middle of a global
crisis that's affecting their citizens
lives and interests they want to be
heard loudly and that's why they are in
Russia and could soon travel to Ukraine
obviously the the conflict is more
complicated more complex than that and
that it will take more than just a round
of African head of state going there and
and preaching good feelings while
there's no guarantees Africa's
initiative could change the Dynamics of
the war in Ukraine a bolder Russian role
in Africa could escalate an already
tense struggle for power in the
continent
Saint Petersburg